>> Third period about
to get underway here at the
MTS Centre in a 2-1 game for
the Anaheim Ducks.
No scoring in period
number two.
Andrew Copp finds a lane and
blows one by Jonathan Bernier.
Jets have the 1-0 lead.
Pavlec the save off of Fowler.
Logan shot, bats in the rebound.
That was a shorthanded tally and
then Getzlaf leads the attack.
It ends up on the stick of
Rickard Rakell, who finds some
room on the short side.
And that's the way we stand
going into the third period.
>> And the third
period starts for the Winnipeg
Jets with a power play.
They had a little bit of a
mix-up there at the end of
number two.
Right now they have
Kesler's number on the board as
Kesler, Perry in the box for the
Ducks, and Mark Scheifele for
the Winnipeg Jets.
>> Yeah, probably
Corey Perry's penalty because
they'll saw off Kesler and
Scheifele, the original
combatants. and then, as you
mentioned, it was Corey
Perry that came in and grabbed
Blake Wheeler.
So the Jets do have the power
play, fourth power play of the
night for the Winnipeg Jets,
as they're down by one.
Fowler, and he'll dig it free,
clear it to the line.
Kept in, knocked down by Blake
Wheeler, for Dustin Byfuglien.
Into the slot. Brian Little,
a shot, and Cam Fowler got
in front of that.
>> Ducks so good at
getting sticks in passing and
shooting lanes.
>> Getzlaf couldn't
handle it. on it is Adam Lowry
for Blake Wheeler.
Wheeler put it to the front of
the net.
No one could get a stick on it.
After it is Nick Petan for
Adam Lowry, back for Petan.
The Ducks very aggressive on
the penalty kill.
Wheeler back up top for
Byfuglien.
The wrist shot, Bernier to
save, rebound and cleared away.
Petan back for Byfuglien.
Byfuglien into the slot looking
for Little.
Getzlaf knocked it away.
Petan sends it down low.
Bieksa with Little after him.
Lowry helps out.
Lowry is up with it for Wheeler
in front, trying to go backside.
That got tipped away and it will
slip out to centre ice.
Petan very quickly back in for
Blake Wheeler.
Wheeler takes a bump, leaves it
for Byfuglien.
Around for Andrew Copp.
35 seconds in the power play,
Copp couldn't handle it.